so for my diagram project I decided to
look at the mobile version of reddit.com
and I started by opening up the HTML
this is a cleaned up version everything
starts by requesting the HTML when we
receive it we immediately start building
and parsing the Dom in the head of the
file we find this CSS file compact CSS
so we fire off a request for it and
continue parsing the Dom in the next
line down we find this script for Google
Analytics but it's marked async so it's
not part of the critical rendering path
and we can ignore it for this exercise
here we've requested jQuery so we fire
off the request and block the parser at
this point the preload scanner kicks in
which looks down the HTML for other
resources that can start downloading it
finds reddit init je s and the header
and it finds another script mobile jazz
in the body and immediately starts their
downloads when the CSS arrives we build
the CSS on which unblocks jQuery is and
Retta init jeaious which gets a run
right here then we continue building the
Dom will then run the last javascript
file mobile GIS which we can actually
find down inside the body of the script
down here which finally lets us render
the page looking at the metrics of the
page this leaves us with five critical
resources the HTML the CSS file and then
the three JavaScript files to find the
number of critical bytes we just need to
add up the sizes of all of our critical
resources which gives us ninety nine
point six kilobytes and in the best case
scenario it's going to take five round
trips to collect all the files that we
need for the site